it may be hard to believe but there is
actually one evil mastermind behind all
of the major events of judu kaisen and I
mean Mastermind in the most literal way
possible because the ultimate villain of
the entire series is just a brain at the
end of the Shibuya incident Arc the
impostor pretending to be suguro
revealed his true identity Kaku now this
sorcerer has used his powers to implant
his own brain into other hosed bodies
and it's not a normal brain either it's
got a freaky mouth which makes it at
least 10% more cursed than it already is
and over the course of 1,000 years he's
committed all kinds of very terrible
atrocities at one point being known as
the most evil sorcerer in history and
honestly if you ask me he is still the
most evil sorcerer in history as well
but not only is he the most evil one
he's also one of the most powerful
figures in the entire world and history
of Jud suisen and even at the point
where we haven't seen the full extent of
his true power it is very clear that he
has the powers at least of a special
grade Sorcerer And probably then some
really only characters like sukuna
himself or Satur Gojo really make him
hesitate but he'll gladly take on other
fighters of any level without any fear
but what really makes this mysterious
figure so willing to go head-to-head
with the other most powerful characters
in this show and besides that maybe one
of the most well-written evil
antagonists in all of anime well for one
kenj who has a complete Mastery over the
basic building block of judu kaizen's
power system which is cursed energy
being able to utilize massive quantities
of it with absolute ease and this is
what allows him to be an excellent
hand-to-hand Fighter by enhancing his
physical attributes with cursed energy
after all he has literally hundreds of
years of experience using that exact
power but in addition to that he's also
mastered other really impressive
applications of cursed energy such as
barrier techniques and can even use a
domain expansion without even setting up
a barrier a feat that we've only seen
matched by sakuna himself now we're
already getting into manga territory
here but in his fight against Yuki he
activates a domain expansion called womb
profusion but other than the disturbing
name that it has we don't really know
yet what it specifically does other than
pack a crazy punch however his true
power which makes him so unique comes
from the innate technique that only he
has because kaku's innate curse
technique allows him to to switch bodies
which means that he's assumed tons of
different identities over the course of
judu history sadly enough only a few of
these mysterious identities have been
known but it's assumed that he's
secretly been many people over time and
I use the word secretly lightly because
it's pretty obvious that someone is
actually kenju due to the massive
surgical scar on their foreheads what's
even more impressive though is that he
doesn't just take over people's physical
bodies Kaku can also steal someone's
memories and even even their curse
technique giving him quite the
collection of deadly abilities which now
brings us to the main part of this video
because he has been working on this
master plan of his for centuries using
each of his different identities to work
towards his ultimate goal so who has he
been and why has he chosen to take over
these specific bodies so let's take a
closer look at each and every one of
kaku's identities and the earliest known
identity is of course well Kaku himself
because obviously there has to be a
first kinjaku before he actually started
inhabiting other people's bodies now it
is very much unclear whether certain
Feats were done as this original kinjaku
or later down the line under different
name however one thing that we do know
is that even during the ancient era the
peak era of jyutsu he was already
supremely powerful one thing that we
know is that he was once friends with
the similarly old Tangen and he's also
the person who finally figured out how
to turn a sorcerer into a cursed object
object after the death allowing sukuna
for example to be turned into the 20
fingers that Yuji would one day eat now
maybe the most renowned of kaku's
identities was that of noritoshi camo
the so-called most evil sorcerer in
history this is of course not to be
confused with his descendant here
noritoshi camo the Kyoto jyutsu high
school student and as a camo the OG
noritoshi was part of the Big Three jutu
Families though he's now considered a
stain on that family tree now his
claimed to evil Fame here was his
creation of the cursed womb death
paintings these were kaku's very first
attempt at creating beings Beyond
Humanity or cursed Spirits here's what
he did he kidnapped and held a woman
prisoner who was capable of giving birth
to human Spirit hybrids and it was this
wicked experiments with this ability
that led to the creation of the death
paintings though I have got to say
despite his messed up Origins choso here
did turn out to be a pretty nice guy in
the end and so it's through his ancestry
that choso was actually able to use the
family's special technique which is
blood manipulation and it's actually
possible that kenju can also use this
technique since he does gain the
abilities to use of the innate
techniques of the body that he inhabits
as a brain resulting in him collecting
many Powers throughout the centuries
most of which we've yet to see him use
but moving on for now the next Kaku
identity that we know of jumping ahead
several hundred years is Ki itadori
that's right Kaku is none other than
itadori yuji's mom like this isn't even
a meme or a bit here the main villain of
the series is canonically the main
character's mother and due to kaku's
manipulative nature it does seem like he
probably had a hand in creating Yuji and
probably has a hidden motive for doing
so since he is the main character even
though it often doesn't feel like that
and therefore he's probably extra
special in some way and also due to this
the death paintings technically actually
are yuji's siblings in a way or half
siblings so when chosa recognizes Yuji
as his brother well he is not wrong now
we don't actually know all that much
about Ki other than the reveal that she
was possessed by Kaku and had the
signature forehead scar we really
haven't learned all that much about her
however we do know her innate curse
technique but more on that a little bit
later because for now the last known
vessel for kenju and his current one at
least is the one that we know the most
about out the special great sorcerer
suguru GTO former bestie of Goo Satur
and known human hater now after gto's
death at the hands of his best IG Gojo
his body became the current vessel for
kinjaku and this is of course also what
allowed him access to gto's innate
technique of curse Spirit manipulation
an ability that would be instrumental in
activating his master plans and so
shortly after assuming suguru gto's
identity Kaku actually Allied himself
with the so-called disaster curses and
if you need a quick refresher this team
consisted of Maho the human curse Joo
the volcano curse Hanami the nature
curse and Dagon the ocean curse and this
group of special great curses has the
goal of completely wiping out Humanity
so that curses can become the dominant
species on Earth and so basically what
happens is that they meet with kinjaku
who is at this point posing as GTO who
allies with them in order to help them
get rid of Gojo satu using the prison
realm here now on the Sur they have a
lot in common actually both ghetto and
the disaster curses do hate humans since
ghetto seems to see them as below
sorcerer level and ghetto even goes as
far as calling regular humans who can't
manipulate cursed energy monkeys and
believe that they are completely
inferior beings plus of course he also
has all the reasons to want revenge
against Gojo for defeating him in the
past however of course in reality Kaku
actually has an ulterior motive and now
just to be clear it is true that he
actually does want to get Gojo out of
the way just like he's the biggest
obstacle for the disaster curses he is
also the biggest obstacle and threat to
kinjaku because you know Kaku has a plan
that has been a thousand years in the
making and he can't just let Gojo go
ruin it but there's also another reason
for him to Ally with these curses and it
comes right down to how he's a master
manipulator who's just using everyone
around them for his own goals all along
because instead of doing all the work
himself self Kaku allows these disaster
curses to use their immense strength and
power to start enacting his plans for
him so yeah really if there's one thing
we know throughout the story everything
that Kaku does is manipulative I mean
what's more manipulative than literally
taking over someone's body I guess right
and so Kaku Delights in making people
bend to his whims all the while thinking
that they're working in their own
self-interest and so really no matter
the situation kenju apparently is always
in complete control and uses his
tactical genius to stay several steps
ahead of his enemies and he even hides
the true extent of most of his power so
that he can have the upper hand in
combat as well but now you might be
asking why is he doing any of this in
the first place what is kaku's real end
goal here that took a millennium to
prepare well to tell you about that
we're going to have to dive deep into
some manga spoiler so while everything
so far is covered in the shabuya
incident in season 2 of the anime from
here on out we're looking at what we
know about Kaku from the manga so far as
well okay so what is it well kaku's
motive in the story is to test the
literal limits of cursed energy and push
beyond all conventions and boundaries of
the powers within juud kaisen in fact he
believes that human beings who wield
cursed energy and cursed Spirits can't
be the end all Beall of jujitsu and so
he does believe that something even
greater than either of these entities
must be possible in fact this this is
exactly why he tried making the cursed
womb death paintings in the first place
back when he assumed the identity of
norit toosi camo but ultimately kenju
determined that the death paintings were
failures because his children could not
end up surpassing him in the end he came
to believe that nothing that he
personally could create would ever be
able to surpass himself so he made it
his goal to use uncontrollable
unpredictable chaos to advance his goals
instead and so enter the culling game
basically a lethal Battle Royale that
pits Japan's strongest Jud to sorcer us
throughout history against one another
which is I guess what finally allowed
gig akutami the author of Jutsu kaisen
to finally write his take on a manga
classic the tournament Arc because you
know who doesn't love a good battle
shown in staple however in a kind of
nasty twist this entire tournament is
actually a ritual which draws out huge
amounts of cursed energy at once in fact
at least one of his other identities but
probably a lot more of them which so far
are still unknown made binding vows with
several really powerful Sorcerers from
the past so that they could one day
compete in the coling games by coming
back to life and basically by promising
them a second chance at life through
reincarnation he convinced these
sorceress to be turned into cursed
objects that could be resurrected later
on and these of course include truly
powerful Fighters like for example hajim
mimo who can even pair on pair with the
likes of sukuna and really this shows
just how long kenju has been working on
this master plan in the present day he
was able to activate the spirits of
these Sorcerers to take over human
vessels that he had prepared all along
so that these Warriors of the past could
participate in his game in fact all of
this happens in a very similar way to
how Yuji ended up becoming a vessel for
sukuna so yeah basically with humans
ingesting cursed objects that contained
the Sorceress cursed Energy Plus on top
of that some other regular people
suddenly were awakened at as sorceress
who hadn't formerly had access to Cursed
energy before that now how the entire
ritual of the culling games actually
works is a little bit complicated
honestly and we don't have every single
detail quite yet but basically kaku's
ultimate plan here seems to be to use
this concentration of cursed energy to
fuse every non sorcerer human being in
Japan with Master Tangen and in case you
don't remember Tangen is the ancient
sorcerer who lives in the tombs under
judu high school generating the barriers
protect the Judes to high campuses now
Tang's ability have already transcended
Humanity making her Immortal in fact she
has been living for so long that she
actually knew kenju 1,000 years ago when
both were still young apparently they
were even friends at one point but
clearly there has been quite a lot of
division between them over the last past
1,000 years and now since Tangen star
vessel was actually killed during the
hidden inventory Arc she wasn't actually
able to merge with her and as a result
tenen is now evolving at a truly
alarming rate usually by merging with
the star vessel she's able to pause the
alarming rate of that Evolution but now
her appearance doesn't even appear human
anymore as a result Kaku now plans on
using the fact that Tangen has already
become something Beyond human to his
advantage in fact as it turns out the
real reason that kenju used the disaster
curses is because he needed their power
specifically the power of Maho here by
using suguru ultimate Tech teique
maximum Uzumaki he is able to absorb the
innate techniques of powerful cursed
Spirits because he needed Mao's powers
of idol Transfiguration because that's
the key to taking down the powerful
barrier around tenen which is no easy
feat honestly since tenen is the most
powerful barrier user in all of history
but of course this is yet another proof
that kenju is a true master manipulator
he got four special grade curses who
hated Humanity to essentially eventually
complete his plan for him kenju truly is
always using others for his own purposes
he used the disaster curses to help him
seal Gojo and he promised the ancient
sorceress to be turned into cursed
objects just so that he could use them
later on as sacrifices in his culling
games and when he needed even more
Bloodshed to occur during the culling
games to draw out even more cursed
energy from panic and fear he even
manipulated the entire US government by
convincing the president about cursed
Energy's potential military applications
causing tons of soldiers to be
slaughtered as they entered the combat
zones without any Mastery of cursed
energy but let's get back to Tan's
master plan here though because as we
mentioned by dissolving his protective
barrier and completing the culling games
kenju plans to force Humanity to evolve
into a state Beyond its current
existence by forcefully fusing all of
Japan's non Sorcerers with Tangen and
unfortunately for Japan and the world
kenju has already managed to dissolve
the protective barrier the this was of
course despite Tangen being guarded by
the special grade sorcerer Yuki you know
the lady who makes a habit of asking
much younger boys what type of girls
they like and for a minute there it
actually looked like Kaku was on the
ropes because the combined efforts of
Yuki and choso who again is technically
kind of kaku's son I guess gave him a
real challenge there it seems you see
Yuki's curse technique manipulates
gravity which seems like it would quite
literally crush anything that Kaku could
throw at her however he was actually
able to conjure up the curse techniques
of one of his previous bodies to counter
Yuki's ability and this was in fact the
technique of none other than yuji's
mother Ki itadori whose curse technique
is called the anti-gravity system which
truly was a huge Stroke of Luck because
kenju had to battle Yuki and her gravity
based Powers truly it is quite literally
the perfect counter so really who knows
how many other secret techniques from
his previous bodies Kaku has still lying
around ready to use at the perfect
moment to catch his opponents off guards
and it is exactly having this huge
assortment of techniques to choose from
that is the one thing that helps Kaku
stay one step ahead of everyone else as
he enacts his plan and to be honest
which is the reason why I think he's
such a fascinating antagonist even kenju
himself has apparently no idea what the
result of his culling game ritual will
actually be he's just genuinely curious
to see what will happen to the point
where he even believes that if the
resulting be just takes the shape of a
silly face it'll just be comical to him
even as he essentially Dooms the rest of
humanity as we know it because after all
As We Know Kaku definitely does have a
sense of humor as opposed to a lot of
anime antagonists who are deadly serious
and calm cool and collected at all times
Kaku let's be real is pretty silly
sometimes and this is actually best
displayed I think in his battle with
fumihiko takaba now fumihiko is one of
the ordinary people who suddenly found
themselves with cursed powers at the
start of the calling games you see
fumihiko takaba is a comedian Al by a
failed one however his curse technique
is entirely based on his comedy style
and involves turning his imagination
into reality which is an ability that
will become ridiculously powerful should
he ever be able to master it and as he
tries to take down the Mastermind kenju
it becomes just as much of a battle of
wits as a battle of strength however
much to takaba surprise as they test
each other to see who can make the other
laugh Kaku might actually be a lot
funnier than the professional comedian
he's a true master of creating goofy
faces and even knows a lot about various
popular comedy TV programs in Japan so
much like Gojo it seems he apparently
had a lot of time to watch his share of
movies in between creating his evil
schemes I guess and in general Kaku has
actually adapted surprisingly well to
the modern era considering that he is
1,000 years old really you'd expect him
to be kind of behind the times but in
addition to keeping up with television
he can also be seen playing the game of
life with a disaster curses but this is
of course nothing compared to the time
that kinjaku just pulls out a whole
iPhone so he can read chapter 236 of juk
kaisa oh okay okay so it's actually I
think it's implied that he actually just
has some kind of surveillance operating
so he can check out the Gojo versus
sukuna fight from afar but since the
literal manga panel of Gojo's death is
super imposed over his phone screen it
definitely just looks like Kuku straight
up downloaded the Shen Jump app here by
the way the man has definitely adapted
to the 21st century and all of its
technological Marvels that come with it
pretty impressive for someone who lived
all the way back during the hyan area of
Japan and so really that's just another
way that this villain continues to shock
the audience and defy all expectations
his over 1,000-year-old culling game
plan is really for little other than
just his own Twisted amusement and sense
of curiosity for his own entertainment
kenju is perfectly willing to sacrifice
the entire population of Japan just so
he can see what happened happens he's at
one time cold and calculating while also
being funloving in the most deranged and
chaotic ways imaginable and really I
think it's exactly this that allowed him
to set his calling game plan in action
and lead to the most intense judu kaisen
Arc yet where we're going to find out
even more about this evil mastermind and
more importantly have some more truly
epic battles and perhaps the biggest
mystery still is what role Yuji actually
has to play in all of this because
surely Yuji being able to act as a
vessel for sukuna and being literally
birthed by the main villain of the story
must have some major connections but
what part he plays in kaku's plan is
still a complete mystery and on top of
that with all of kaku's crazy Powers
watching even a single fight of his can
get really hard to R your mind around
since he's busting out curse techniques
left and right at this point and between
curse technique and reverse curse
technique and inate technique there are
just so many techniques to understand
but thankfully understanding all of
these can be pretty easy all all you
have to do is watch my entire video that
explains the whole Jud kaisen power
system in easy to understand words I
hope at least so uh make sure to check
out that thanks so much for watching and
I will see you in the next one